[MUSIC PLAYING]
PATRICK SWEENEY: Thank you all.
It's a pleasure to be here.
I'm really very honored to
be giving a Google talk.
It's exciting for me.
I was looking forward to
this for quite a long time.
And we're going to talk today
about the surprising power
of fear.
And I could have never
imagined the things
that Elaine had mentioned.
If you look in the
background, that's
me, actually going down
across one of the glaciers
on Mount Elbrus, the
highest mountain in Europe.
And I could have never even
imagined that 15 years ago.
So I'm here to share a
little bit of that journey.
Before we get
started, tell me, who
today has made a
decision based on fear?
Raise your hands.
OK.
Who in the past week has made
a decision based on fear?
OK.
So if you think about it--
I think we've got a very
confident group here,
or there might be a little
bit of a confidence bias--
if you think about
the reason you stopped
at a red light this
morning on your way
into work, walking into
work or biking into work,
was the motivation behind
that fear or something else?
There's only two motivations
in your decision making.
We're going to talk about
that in a little bit.
So according to Dr. Srini
Pillay at Harvard, 88% of us
harbor hidden fears.
And of course, if
you ask anyone, no.
I don't have any hidden fears.
Because they're hidden, or
else they wouldn't have them.
So we're going to explore
that a little bit today.
Because it affects
your emotions.
And if you look at
Jane, here, so you're
not Mr. Perfect, Brad, but
marriage means more to me
than love ever could.
So she has some hidden fears,
obviously, of being abandoned
and that sort of thing.
The latest research that
we have available to us
shows that the only
way to conquer fear
is to find more of it.
Most people don't realize that.
That to really tame fear,
you have to find more of it.
So there's only two
choices you have.
You can either tame fear,
or fear can tame you.
There's no in-between.
Ripping the lid off
those hidden fears
will dramatically
change your life.
They're going to
change your emotions.
They'll change how you deal
with your colleagues at work,
they'll change how you deal
with your friends and family,
and they'll change how
you feel about yourself.
So today, I'm going to go
into a three-step framework,
using the latest
neuroscience, that's
going to help you rip the
lid off those hidden fears
and learn how to use
that fear as fuel.
That's the exciting part is
when you can get to the point
where that fear doesn't
become something you avoid,
but rather it becomes a
source of fuel for you.
So it's going to
make you happier.
It's going to make
you more successful,
and it's going to bring
about world peace.
And I'll cover that
in about 30 minutes.
Now, you Googlers
should be impressed.
Because the Dalai Lama
takes about an hour
to get to his world speech part.
I'm going to do it
in half the time.
So it's 50% more efficient,
even though the Lama
is a big hitter.
So my mission has been
to bring fear to people
and to help people
find more of it.
I've worked with CEOs,
professional athletes, US
Special Forces, and we
found some amazing things,
and I'm going to
share that with you.
One of the things that's
clear is we all have a gift,
and that gift is inside.
And oftentimes, fear keeps
it locked in to people.
So I'm going to start out today,
before we get into the science,
with a gift for all of you.
Whenever I come
to a new country,
I like to do something
to celebrate the culture.
So I'm going to sing
"Frere Jacques,"
a traditional Swiss
lullaby, but I can't sing.
So we're a little
pressed for time.
I usually ask for
volunteers, but Elaine said
we don't have so much time.
So I'm going to pick five
people from the audience
to come up and sing with me.
And I'm going to start out with
you, sir, in the gray shirt.
Ma'am, you with the kind
of cranberry-colored shirt
back there.
And ma'am, back there,
with the flowered shirt on.
Yes, please.
Come on up.
Yeah.
Come on right up here.
And sir, with the glasses on.
Please come over here.
Ma'am, even though
you're not looking at me,
I can still see you.
Come on.
Come on up.
You'll be our last one.
OK.
Now, we have these five folks.
If I could ask your name.
AUDIENCE: Andres.
PATRICK SWEENEY: Andres.
AUDIENCE: Jana.
PATRICK SWEENEY: Jana.
AUDIENCE: Maria.
PATRICK SWEENEY: Maria.
AUDIENCE: Xander.
PATRICK SWEENEY: Xander.
AUDIENCE: Juana.
PATRICK SWEENEY: Juana.
AUDIENCE: Andrea.
PATRICK SWEENEY: Andrea.
OK.
So we've got these
six folks up here
who either are going to
become the stars of Google--
because this is going out
to hundreds of thousands
of people, who will see
it all over the world, all
over Google's
organization, everywhere.
So they're either going
to be tremendous stars,
or they're going to
be looking for work,
looking for a new
spouse and partner,
and living in some
shack in the woods
because they embarrassed
themselves so badly.
So don't think
about that though.
What I want you to think about
is just what we're going to do.
OK.
Come on in a little closer.
On three, we're going
to-- one, two, three.
Frere Jacques, Frere
Jacques, dormez vous?
Dormez vous?
You all know the words, right?
OK.
So we're going to start out.
One, two, three.
Fr-- oh, no.
I can't believe you guys
thought I was actually
going to make you sing.
OK.
Nobody is going to sing up here.
And if you're in the
audience, and you
were thinking you
might get picked,
I want you to stop right now
and answer the same question
I'm going to ask these guys.
How do you feel?
AUDIENCE: Relieved.
PATRICK SWEENEY:
You feel relieved.
A second ago-- a second
ago, how did you feel?
Let's say, before
you felt relieved.
How'd you feel?
AUDIENCE: Ridiculous.
PATRICK SWEENEY: Ridiculous.
OK.
And when you say you felt
ridiculous, where in your body
did you feel ridiculous?
Can you pinpoint-- where?
AUDIENCE: In my mind.
PATRICK SWEENEY: In your mind.
Can you pinpoint a
physical location?
No?
OK.
Who else felt nervous
or embarrassed?
OK.
Well we've got-- so
let's start down here.
Where did you feel it?
AUDIENCE: I am all shaking.
PATRICK SWEENEY:
You're all shaking.
Your hands are shaking.
We can see that here.
OK.
So your whole body's shaking.
That's awesome.
And you?
AUDIENCE: I had no idea what
song you were talking about.
PATRICK SWEENEY: Yeah,
it is-- you didn't know
what song I was talking about?
But she was still ready to sing.
God love you.
Good for you.
And where do you
feel it physically?
Is there someplace in your body?
AUDIENCE: Some right here.
PATRICK SWEENEY: Just
kind of in your heart,
in your stomach, and
that sort of thing.
And you?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
[LAUGHS]
PATRICK SWEENEY: Tight
jaw, tight shoulders?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Maybe also trembling a bit?
PATRICK SWEENEY:
Trembling in the knees.
A little Elvis leg?
Right?
You can't get the leg to stop.
OK.
Well, give them a round
of applause, please.
Have a seat.
Thank you very much.
So if you are in the
audience, and you
were afraid you
were going to get
picked, what I want you to think
about is where you felt it.
Stop for a second and think,
physically, where you had it.
Do we have any poker
players in the room?
Anyone who plays poker?
No?
Does anyone know what a tell is?
What's a tell?
AUDIENCE: Me?
PATRICK SWEENEY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: It's when
you give away--
that you're saying
something about what
you're thinking right now.
PATRICK SWEENEY: It's a
subconscious gesture, behavior,
or emotion that you do when
you have something good.
So poker players
call this a tell.
You might pull on your ear.
You might straighten
out your shirt sleeve.
Or there's something
you might do
that can give away the fact
that you've got a good hand.
That's called a tell in poker.
Every single person
has a fear tell.
We have a way that fear
manifests itself in your body.
And that grows depending
on the level of fear.
We're going to talk about
that in a little bit.
Because it's important that you
start to understand your fear
tells because they start
to give you messages.
When you see an email from
one of your colleagues
or your boss, and you
start to feel that tell,
maybe you'll feel it
right there, where--
I think it was Andreas was
saying he felt it a little bit.
Or maybe you'll feel
it down in your legs.
But you start to
recognize those tells.
Most people do a
lot to avoid that.
And I want to tell you, to
be the best version of you,
and to let out
everything you have
and not make decisions
based on fear,
you want to find more of that.
So it's taken me an awful
long time to figure out
the neuroscience behind it
because I've interviewed
over 35 leading neuroscientists
from MIT, Harvard, Tufts,
Trinity, all over the world.
And some of the
technology we have,
just in the past five
years, has allowed
us to have a look into the brain
and understand how some of this
works.
I had a hidden fear, and
I didn't recognize it
until it was almost too late.
Elaine mentioned that I had
started a few technology
companies.
So I was a CEO of a
venture-backed company.
We were really
hot and successful
in the software space.
And I was working 70
or 80 hours a week,
typical VC-backed type of CEO.
And I was going out every night
to these networking events
and CEO events and
private equity events.
And I was drinking six or
seven beers every night
when I went out.
And then I come back at
about midnight or so,
and I'd feel guilty.
It's that whole Irish
Catholic thing, right?
You're a redhead.
You get that.
So [LAUGHS] it was crazy.
And I woke up one
morning, went to the gym,
just like you guys
probably do here.
Went into the gym.
Hey, Sweeney!
How are you doing?
Good!
Got to work arms today.
Started working arms, ooh.
Boy, that arm
hurts a little bit.
All right.
Well, I'll just do
a little cardio.
Get on the machine.
Then the next day,
I got in, woke up.
Same thing.
Starting to feel really bad.
And I thought, wow.
I should go to the doctor
and get this checked out.
And I didn't.
Can anyone guess why?
AUDIENCE: Afraid
to get bad news?
PATRICK SWEENEY: I was
afraid to go to the doctor.
Yeah.
I was afraid to get bad news.
Third day, woke up.
I could barely move the arm.
I said, I've got to
go to the doctor now.
So I went to the doctor, and
he looked at it, and he said,
you know, it looks
like a staph infection.
That's pretty common among
guys who spent a lot of time
in the gym and working out.
So we're going to give
you some antibiotics,
and we're going to
take a few blood tests.
The nurse will call you
back in the afternoon.
I said, OK.
Good.
Thanks.
Well, the nurse
didn't call me back.
The doctor did.
And that's when my life changed.
He said, I don't
know what it is,
and we can't figure it out
here in our little hospital
in Virginia.
We're going to send you
up to Johns Hopkins.
One of the top
hospitals in the world.
So I got the express ticket
to the Johns Hopkins matinee
for leukemia patients.
And I went up there,
and I got checked in.
And I got put into this bed.
And I had a one-year-old
daughter at the time.
And I had my wife, who was
six months pregnant, with me,
who was just white as a ghost.
Stressed out as you could be.
I had more tubes
and wires plugged
in me than the space shuttle,
just about to lift off.
And I'm sitting in this bed, and
all of a sudden, Dr. McDevitt
walks in.
He takes two steps inside the
door, looks across the room.
There were three
kids behind him who
I thought were the kids he
must coach in the soccer team
after work, because they didn't
look a day older than 12.
And he stopped, and he
turned to look at them.
And he said, oh, wow.
This is really interesting.
This guy's T-cells
went rogue and started
attacking the rest of
his white blood cells.
He's got no immune system.
And he's talking like
I wasn't even there.
I'm like, hey, doc.
Yeah, but the good news is
I got the first colonoscopy
in the morning.
And he didn't even laugh.
He came over, and he sat down.
And he said, look.
We're going to do
a lot of tests.
We're going to try and figure
some of this stuff out.
But are your affairs in order?
Now, I'm no Doogie Howser,
but when a doctor asks you
if your affairs are in order,
you're pretty much screwed.
Does anyone not know who
Doogie Howser is, by the way?
Oh, God, I hate all you people!
You missed the Dalai Lama
joke too, from Caddyshack.
Does anyone know
any '80s trivia?
Who knows the '80s trivia?
Stay with me.
Someone?
Anyone?
OK.
All right.
Couple people.
Doogie Howser was a prodigy
doctor who was like 12 years
old as a doctor.
So anyways, they started
figuring stuff out,
and it didn't look good at all.
It was a really rare
form of leukemia.
I had no immune
system, and my body
was being attacked constantly.
I sat there, and
like Elaine said,
I had spent five years
training for the Olympics.
My first Olympic
trials, I finished 14th.
The second Olympic
trials, I finished second.
The difference
between those two was
I did a ton of mental training.
I was in Colorado Springs at
the US Olympic Training Center,
learning how to use my
mind to get my body faster.
So when I sat in
there in Hopkins,
and they were telling
me there's not
much they think they can do,
and they've never seen something
like this before, I said, OK.
Well, there's something
I've got to do.
I sat there day and night,
imagining these warrior cells
coming out of my body and
attacking those rogue T-cells.
And I just sat there, and
I envisioned it day in
and day out for two weeks.
My body building up
these warrior cells.
And I had the greatest
doctors in the world.
And I kept doing that.
And not to give away
the ending, but I died.
I didn't die.
I'm here.
I lived.
And when I got out of
the hospital at Hopkins,
I walked out, and it was in
the worst part of Baltimore.
It's in a ghetto area.
It's really rundown.
And I walked out, and I
saw this leaf in a puddle.
And it was red and tinged
with gold around the outside.
I would have never even stopped
before this all had happened.
I stopped, and I looked
down, and I thought, wow,
that's really beautiful.
I know it sounds cliche, but it
was like this gratitude switch
got flipped on in my head.
And all I could think about was
how awesome it was to be alive
and how much I had wasted
my life worrying about fear.
Being afraid of everything.
And I didn't even know how
afraid I was of all the things
that were going on in
my life until I got out
of that hospital, and
I faced my real fear.
When I faced that real fear,
I realized fear was a fraud.
A complete fraud.
I found this study from Cornell
University called The Legacy
Study.
What they did was they
interviewed thousands of people
between the age of 70 and 109.
And they said, we
want to collect
the wisdom of our elders.
So they asked them a
bunch of questions.
Asked them for
their best advice.
There was only one
thing of the thousands
of people that was common
around just about all of them.
And that was that
they wished they
had spent less time worrying.
They wish they had spent less
time in their life in fear.
Because fear is all about
the future or something bad
that happened in the past.
So if you're living
in the present,
and you're enjoying
the moment, you
can't be in a fearful state.
Fear is like a Rottweiler.
You get a little
Rottweiler puppy,
you can throw it in a cage,
and you can occasionally
toss him scraps.
That thing won't be able to hold
itself back if you let it out,
because it's going to
tear at your flesh just
to get something to eat.
If you take that
same Rottweiler,
and you care for it, and you
bring it into the family,
and you feed it,
and you train it,
that thing will do whatever it
takes to keep your family safe.
It will become your best friend.
Fear is the exact same
way, but most of us
do our best to ignore it.
So I want everyone to
stand up for just a second.
Pretend you're that Rottweiler.
Shake it out.
OK.
Now, I'm going to let
everyone in on a secret.
And this is one of the key
fear secrets to start with.
You are going to die.
And you are going to die.
And we're all going to die.
I want everyone to repeat
after me, I will die.
AUDIENCE: I will die.
PATRICK SWEENEY: Louder.
I will die!
AUDIENCE: I will die!
PATRICK SWEENEY: One more time.
I will die!
AUDIENCE: I will die!
PATRICK SWEENEY: OK.
Now, is anyone
unclear about that?
All right.
Sit down.
Because now we can live.
Now, if you're afraid of dying--
and that's one of the biggest
fears in the world--
no matter what your spirituality
is, there is no argument,
we're going to go back
to wherever we came from.
So I want everyone to close
their eyes for a second,
especially if you're
afraid of dying,
and I want you to think about
yourself dying, right now.
If you were afraid to
get up here and on stage
and be embarrassed
or feel ridiculous,
I want you to think
about that right now.
All of those things
happened in your mind.
That was a movie you
played in your mind.
And fear is always
a horror movie.
So think about the worst movie
you can think of right now.
Standing on the edge
of a cliff, getting
thrown in water with a
bunch of great white sharks,
whatever your biggest fear is.
Think about it now
and try and feel
the sensations in your
body that are changing.
Feel where you're
feeling it in your belly
and your hips and your chin
and your jaw and your knees,
anywhere you're feeling that.
Now, here's what I
want you to do when you
feel that for the next time.
Take a deep breath in
to a count of four.
Hold it for a count of four.
And let it out for
a count of four.
In.
Two, three, four, hold it.
Two, three, four.
[EXHALES] Two, three, four.
In.
[INHALES] Hold it.
Two, three, four.
Out.
If you keep that rhythm up,
when you get in a fear state--
I'll explain a little bit
of the science behind it--
you change from having
an erratic heartbeat--
which if you looked on an
EKG is a heartbeat that
looks like a silhouette
of mountains--
to having a coherent heartbeat,
which is just a nice sine wave.
That allows you to take over
your sympathetic nerve system
again.
Because it gets hijacked when
you get in a fearful state,
and you stop thinking correctly.
Just that breathing,
that four by four,
is a great way to get you.
So the first step in
this three-step framework
is to start to recognize
your fear tells.
Start to figure out
what your body does
so you can take control
over it, and you
can get back in control.
So I was terribly serious
about the World Peace part.
I think if I can teach millions
of people to tame their fear,
we can have world peace.
Because I believe
what Gandhi said.
He said, hate isn't the enemy.
Fear is the enemy.
And if we can all understand
fear and learn to tame it
and use it as a fuel, we can
get to a place of World Peace.
So to understand fear, you
have to understand what
I refer to as a fear frontier.
Because we've got a battle
going on inside our brains.
I call it the Battle
of the brains,
and it has to do with
two primary glands
within your brain.
The first one is the amygdala.
It's a little almond-shaped
gland that sits at the base
of your brain, and it
handles the three F's.
Anyone know what
the three F's are?
When you get scared?
Fight is one.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: Fight.
PATRICK SWEENEY: Fight.
Flight.
The third one?
AUDIENCE: Freeze.
PATRICK SWEENEY: Freeze.
Exactly.
So the amygdala is what
controls the fight, flight,
or freeze response.
So that is the
gland that saves us
from saber-tooth tigers
and woolly mammoths.
It's been there since
the beginning of time.
What we didn't realize
was that jumping
at the first sign of
rustling grass or freezing
like a deer in the
headlights every time someone
made a loud noise didn't exactly
make us the best dinner guest.
So over the past
50,000 years or so,
we developed something
called the prefrontal cortex.
And the prefrontal cortex
is the adult supervision
for the brain.
What happens in a
normal state, when
we're sitting here right
now, the prefrontal cortex
is in charge.
For most of us, anyways.
Not for me, because I'm scared
to death being up here talking
to you guys.
But the prefrontal
cortex, you can see here,
handles your world
when you're chilled,
when you're maybe a
little bit uneasy.
But then when you start to
get high on the anxiety scale,
on the dread scale, all
the way up to terror,
the amygdala takes over.
And the amygdala is only
making up stories about fear.
You can't measure fear.
You can measure risk, right?
Risk is of all the people in
this room, in our lifetime,
there's going to be seven
people in this room who
die of car crashes.
If we took this same size
room, and we multiplied it
times 50 times,
we'd find one person
who would die in a plane crash.
That's risk.
We understand that.
That's data driven.
Fear is different for all
of us because it's not real.
It doesn't exist.
We make it up in our mind.
It's almost like risk is on
one end of the solar system,
over here in Mercury,
and fear comes out
of the other end of the
solar system from Uranus.
That was a joke.
That's why my 10 and 11-year-old
boys love my jokes when I
throw them in the presentation.
The truth is, fear is a joke.
There is no real basis
for any kind of fear.
So if we can learn to take
this prefrontal cortex
and bring it over here and
make it in control when you're
doing it, this is exactly
the kind of courage
that Special Forces trained for.
And they do it in
just one realm,
and they need to do
it in three realms.
I told you, there's two
ways to make decisions.
One is based on fear, the
other is based on opportunity.
If you think about
every major decision
you've made in your life;
to come to work at Google,
to move to Zurich, to get
in a serious relationship.
Any major decision
you've made in your life,
you've made it either out of
fear or out of opportunity.
Out of opportunity comes
growth and gratitude.
And those are the two
pillars for happiness.
That's why understanding
fear and taming fear
can make you happier.
I mention my 10 and
12-year-old boys for a reason
when I was talking
about the amygdala.
For anyone who has
children or anyone who's
a teacher, who's working with
kids who are under 25 years
old, this is critical to know.
The amygdala is fully
developed at birth.
So they have the fight,
flight, and freeze response
when you're born.
Because that saves you from
the charging woolly mammoth.
The prefrontal cortex,
that doesn't get fully
developed until most people
are in their mid-20s.
So think about that when
you're in a situation where
all of a sudden, a
kid starts screaming,
and you can't figure out, why
can't you just think rationally
about this?
Because he doesn't
have the capability
to think rationally yet.
So someone who's
under 25 needs to be
trained to create
the connections
between the prefrontal
cortex and the amygdala
so that prefrontal
cortex can take control.
And there's three things,
three types of fear
that we're going
to address here.
But the important thing is
even after you're 25 years old,
you can still change.
You can still create
courage because of something
called neuroplasticity.
Neuroplasticity
has only recently
been proven with some of
the new technology we have.
But basically, your mind
can change at any age.
And that's what happened
to me when I finally
faced my fear frontier.
So what I'm hoping
everyone here can do
is figure out what their fear
frontier is and move that out.
And the further you move
that fear frontier out,
the more in control
of your life you are
and the happier you
are going to be.
If you understand the
three fears that exist,
number one is physical.
So we talked about
US Navy SEALs.
And I've worked with
them in the past,
and they are tremendous in
terms of physical courage.
And what they do is
they've got this courage
factory in Coronado, California
called Basic Underwater
Demolition School, or BUDS.
And SEALs go there
for six weeks.
They take the strongest
and bravest candidates
from the normal Navy, and
they bring them to BUDS.
Now it's not surprising
the average age
of a Navy SEAL going through
BUDS is 21 years old.
So they're getting them
before that connection
is fully developed.
And they ratchet up the
amount of physical fear
that they get put in every
day, until the SEALs start
to realize that when they get
that reaction, when they start
to feel the same trembling
knees, the butterflies
in the stomach, the tight
jaw, they can say, OK.
This is our fuel.
This is energy.
We're going to get
something on, and we're
going to kick some ass.
And anyone can learn to do that.
One of the challenges
some of the Navy SEALs
I've worked with
have is they only
learned to do it in
the physical realm.
There's also emotional
fears and instinctual fears,
as you can see from this graph.
And like any other fear,
like any other skill,
you have to practice.
Courage, in those instances.
You've got to understand
what it's like.
Because what happens when
you hit your fear frontier is
cowardice begets cowardice.
My biggest fear was dead
center in the middle of this.
It's flying.
I saw a plane crash, a delta
DC-9, when I was six years old.
All 100 people on board died.
I was terrified to fly.
I had my entire life locked
away from me for 30 years,
and I didn't know it.
And that planted a
seed of cowardice
that crept through
my whole body.
I was a kid in
high school who was
afraid to go to sleep at
night without the light on.
And that's how bad it was.
So my biggest fear
became flying.
But then after I got out of the
hospital, all I could imagine
was my one-year-old daughter.
And would I have
to be the guy who
is remembered by his
daughter as being
too afraid to get on a plane
and take her to Disney World?
And I said, man,
there's no way I want
that to be what I remember.
So I decided to go mano a
mano with my flying fear,
and that changed my whole life.
And what happens from a
physical perspective--
this is a great example
of the type of technology
we've had in the
past five years.
This is from Dr.
Anna Byler, who used
to be at MIT, who just opened
up the neuroscience center
in Bordeaux.
And what you're going to see
now is a mouse's amygdala
creating a pathway to
the prefrontal cortex
and the prefrontal cortex coming
back in the other direction.
So what this shows--
more than anything
else, what this shows
is how amazing the
technological advances have been
in just the past five years.
But what you're seeing here
is that pathway connecting
between the amygdala and
the prefrontal cortex
means that those neurons
are firing together often.
And neurons that fire
together wire together.
So that brain that
you just saw was
creating a highway of courage.
And the more that those neurons
fire together, the easier
it becomes for that
pathway to fire together.
So the more in control that the
prefrontal cortex can become.
That's the second step of
this three part framework.
That second step is to scare
yourself at least once a week,
so you can start to bring
those feelings up and start
to control them.
And ideally, you scare yourself
at a higher and a higher level,
and you start to get in control.
And you wire that pathway
between your amygdala
and your prefrontal cortex.
Our bodies were designed
for physical stress
over thousands and
thousands of years.
And we live in such
a stress-free world.
We avoid stress, and we've
never lived in a safer
time in human history.
We don't even walk
upstairs anymore.
We stand on an escalator,
or we take an elevator.
We don't even carry our
bags in the airport.
We drag them behind
us on wheels.
We try and do everything
we can to avoid stress.
The problem is, our bodies
are wired for stress,
so we have to find more of it.
And that's step three is we
want to build this courage.
We understand there's
neuroplasticity.
It can happen at any time.
All of this can be easier if you
create the right environment.
The right foundation for it.
And that's what I
call fear fitness.
So the three steps are
to learn your fear tells,
scare yourself once a week,
and then stress your body three
to five times a week.
The easiest way to do this
is with aerobic exercise.
It gets better if
you add in strength
or some form of agility.
Rock climbing is a great
example of that, or dancing.
And then lastly,
there's so much new data
around what happens if you go
back to environmental stress.
I tell everyone the
easiest thing to do
is take a cold shower
in the morning.
In the first week, it sucks.
And everyone in here--
everyone I've ever said,
said, no, no, no.
Other people can do that.
I can't take a cold shower.
And everyone says
the same thing.
But you can.
And after a week
or two, it actually
becomes pretty easy to do.
But you're training
your body to handle
those environmental stresses.
I run in the wintertime with
just a pair of shorts on.
And it's a type of
stress that our body
needs because our
genetic array has
been aligned for very
specific instances and very
specific stresses.
And if we're not using those,
it's almost like a race car.
A Ferrari is sitting there
with all these tubes.
It has all these
washers in them.
But because it never gets run,
the washers get all dry rotted,
and they stop working.
That's what your immune
system goes through when
you go through those stresses.
That's what almost killed me.
Because I was living
that life of burying
my fears with beer every
night and 80 hours a week.
So the other thing
that just came out
in the past six weeks
that's really interesting
is your diet plays a
tremendous role in your courage
and your happiness as well.
So if you have the
right gut bacteria,
if you eat yogurt and sauerkraut
and kimchi and the things that
develop the good
bacteria in your gut,
it's quicker to shut
off your amygdala.
So it makes the circuits
to turn the fear response
off much quicker.
And that's data that's
just come out literally
in the past six weeks.
So there's so much
amazing stuff around how
to live a courageous life.
Now what I want to do-- that's
the three step framework.
I want to give you the
five fatal fears that we
see a lot in corporations.
So you can use this to become
authentic, courageous leaders.
And this is from,
like Elaine said,
working with a lot of
CEOs throughout the world
and a lot of government
organization.
We've seen five fatal fears
that are pretty prevalent.
First and foremost is
the fear of the unknown.
You see this a ton in
mergers and acquisition.
Right?
When people acquire
something, they say, OK.
We want to keep the status quo.
It's called a status quo bias.
You also see it in
market leaders too.
Kodak is a perfect example.
Kodak was such a huge,
successful company.
And they said, well,
we don't know anything
about this digital revolution.
We're not going to do anything.
We're not going to get into it.
We're going to sit back and see.
So fear of the unknown.
The second is fear of rejection.
Or fear of rejection from the
tribe is what it boils down to.
The only reason anyone
would feel ridiculous
standing up here,
about to sing--
nothing changes.
Nothing changes in your world.
You're not in physical danger.
There's no reason that you
should have any reaction,
except we're programmed
instinctually
to stick with the tribe,
because it's safer.
100,000 years ago, if you
got rejected from the tribe,
that meant certain death.
You couldn't live.
Today it doesn't
mean that at all.
Today, oftentimes,
in fact, it means
you're an innovator
because you don't
want to be stuck with groupthink
or the sunflower management
that some people refer
to, which is just like,
you do whatever the
leader wants you to do,
so you can keep him
happy or her happy.
So it's crazy.
Apophenia is the second one.
Or sorry, the third one.
Apophenia is finding patterns
where patterns don't exist.
This is most easily seen when
someone has had a few successes
and they get what's called
the winner bias or the success
bias, and they aren't
given the same scrutiny,
or their projects aren't
given the same analysis
that other projects
were, because maybe they
had one or two successful ones.
The fourth one is atychiphobia.
And that is basically
the fear of failure.
It comes down to something
called a stability bias.
We see this more
times in careers
than we necessarily
see it in companies.
But we see people who have
a tremendous skill set,
and they don't want to
do it because they're
afraid they might fail, and they
have something good already.
I use my brother
every now and again
as an example because
he's such a great artist.
He's a federal agent, and he
does law enforcement for the US
government from 9:00 to 5:00.
He's pretty good at his job.
He rushes home to build
custom motorcycles.
And he spends all weekend at
swap meets and going to shows,
and he's sold his motorcycles
in Japan, all over the US,
throughout Europe.
And I've said to him a
bunch of times, Sean,
you ought to do
that for a living.
You'd be making millions of
dollars doing what you love.
He'd say, oh, no.
I've got 15 years, and
I'll get my pension,
and then I can do it full time.
And I see that all the time.
And that's the fear of failure.
People are looking
for that stability.
If you ever hear
someone saying they're
working for the weekend, right?
I can't wait for the weekend.
It means they have
the wrong job.
You have the right
job when you're
able to combine your
passion with your vocation.
And that's what I
call your genius.
If you can spend every
day in your genius,
you love coming to work.
You love doing what you do and
working with the team you're
working with.
If you don't, you're
being held back
because of a fear
decision that you made,
not an opportunity decision.
The fifth one is a fear of loss.
And we see this with
sales teams all the time.
A lot of sales guys will
come from meager backgrounds.
Families that maybe never
had gone to college.
Never made a lot of money.
And they'll start
making $150,000 a year,
and they'll buy the Porsche, and
they'll join the country club.
And these guys start to get
pushed from their VP of sales
or their CEO.
They say, OK.
You can do way more than this.
And they could.
They could do
million dollar years.
They could really have
an incredible life
that they only dreamed of.
But all of a sudden, when
they hit a certain level,
they think, well, what
if I lose the Porsche?
What if I lose the big house?
What if I lose the country club?
So we see this a lot with
sales guys having fear of loss.
And again, it's a decision based
on fear, not on opportunity.
So I'm going to share one
more tool that I put up
on the web for you guys.
And this is a great way,
especially with your teams
or with your personal
decisions, to make a decision.
This is from the stoics
over 2,300 years ago,
and it's called--
I love the name--
pre-meditation of evil.
So when you get trouble, or
you get scared, a lot of people
say, oh, go to your safe place.
Go to your happy place.
That's the worst
thing you can do.
You want to go to
the evil place.
You want to go someplace
where you absolutely think
of the worst scenario possible.
And then you want to
see that happening,
and you want to
create the mitigation
for it, the likely results.
And then that brings you a
whole new level of confidence.
And this is done
by Marcus Aurelius,
who's a famous stoic, who
made this famous years
and years ago.
And there's a whole process
that we use with corporations
to do it.
But it's a great way to
start taking control of life.
Because life only
happens two ways.
Life can either happen to you--
if you're making
decisions based on fear--
and that means you're a victim.
Or life can happen by you.
And you're the
author of your life.
And that means every
decision you're making
is based on an opportunity,
not because of fear.
So I made this
transformation for flying.
When I got out of
the hospital, I
decided to get my
private pilot's license,
and I fell in love with flight.
And I couldn't
believe for 30 years,
this had been completely
locked away from me.
So I got my instrument rating
so I could fly in any weather.
And then I went on and got my
commercial pilot's license.
And I wondered, how many other
people are living in fear
and having the greatest joy
of their life locked away
from them because of a fear?
So that's when I started
trying to convince other people
to go out and find their fear.
So now the kid who
was afraid, who
would cry every time I saw an
airplane, is this guy here.
This is the Green Mountain
Valley Aerobatics School
Aerobatics Contest
in Vermont last year.
And I had more fun doing
this and flying on the water,
in aerobatics, doing all
sorts of different stuff.
And I was just amazed that this
has been held away for so long
for me.
And if you ever get scared
of heights or anything else,
let me know.
I'll take you up for a flight.
So I got second in this
aerobatics competition
last summer in Vermont.
And I know someone out
there is saying, well,
if this fear stuff works so
good, why didn't you get first?
So you try pulling five G's
with your stomach trying
to duck out of your sphincter,
and let me know how easy it is.
Because it's tough.
But it's so [INAUDIBLE].
And I would have never known.
I would have been hidden away.
I would have never traveled to
all the places that I traveled.
I would have never done all the
stuff that I do with my fear.
So what I'd ask you is what
is holding you prisoner
from your greatest joy?
What fears are influencing
the decisions that you make?
So now I've got one last thing.
I want everyone to
stand up one more time.
And we're going to take
the courage code together.
I want you to raise your right
hand, and repeat after me.
I will scare myself once a week.
AUDIENCE: I will scare
myself once a week.
PATRICK SWEENEY: Very good.
I will extend my fear frontier.
AUDIENCE: I will extend
my fear frontier.
PATRICK SWEENEY: I will
face life with courage.
AUDIENCE: I will face
life with courage.
PATRICK SWEENEY: I will make
decisions based on opportunity.
AUDIENCE: I will make
PATRICK SWEENEY: And I
will lead with bravery.
AUDIENCE: And I will
lead with bravery.
PATRICK SWEENEY: When you do, I
promise, your life will change,
and you'll have such
an amazing life.
And what's in here will come
out to share with everyone else.
Thank you all very much.
I'm Patrick Sweeney.
Goodnight.